bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigino ci sono tanti
su tardi deception azzoppa orco demonio
che è successo era un po che non tutti
lavorati eravamo rimasti che la zia
erano ragazzi garanzia prima abbiamo un
contratto sta bambina che aveva il padre
a demoniaco insomma abbiamo passato alle
scimmie la bambina banca capitan sparrow
mi sblocca un altro potere quindi una
velocità posso utilizzare il
teletrasporto me lo dai
questo qualche trasporto va bene lo
compriamo lo compro lo compro hanno
comprato i mille chissenefrega quindi
ragazzi ora posso teletrasportarvi
tecnicamente lana parte all'altra che
figo va bene e cosa mi serve sta roba
niente mi sarò ad andare in giro più
veloce dei trasporti tanto devo correre
come un puledro a teatro la scusa ho
capito quindi quando c'è un nemico
davanti gli passa proprio attraverso
l'uso questa cosa bene userò questa
tecnica contro i pirati demoniaci oki
[ __ ] l'arena le statue in questo posto
sembrano vive buongiorno o pd
la mappa è ufficialmente iniziata il
problema è uno solo
sento di porco demonio mi sono pagato
quindi devo superare le robe con le
spine ma porca put che ne so io quando
arrivano le spine portico demonio in
tutto sto casino sento dei passi
fortissimi stai zitta grazie cento dei
pasti fortissimi e non capisco chi è ma
sono questi con checa l'incredibile ci
sono questi che stanno che stanno ormai
si muovono stanno fermi questa qua la
mia grandissima domani
io non ho capito perché se si muovono
potrebbe essere un problema
ok ok viene misurato ragazzi quanto è
brutta sta cosa quindi mi seguono anche
alla fine mi stanno ufficialmente
seguendo corretto
urca vacca che se io li guardo stanno
fermi 737 te ma che figo cioè vivo una
sega perché fa un po gaga però ok
devo riuscire a girarmi velocemente non
sono morte io non posso giocare questo
gioco la specie poi niente io sono molto
di innumerevoli volte ma completamente a
caso in realtà va bene partiamo sul
serio adesso abbiamo scherzato famoso
poeta e trasportare sono i punti che
conosci quindi occhio mamma mia ragazzi
quanto orribile sta cosa via via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via via puglia no ragazzi
orribile se vi giuro
chi è che si è pensato farò da un malato
di mente
porca vacca stai fermo fermi fermi
e il difficilissimo perché non vedi dove
stai andando ma c'è la gente che ti
segue e pazzesca sta roba che
interrogati come gli minuti me questa
cosa difficilissimo 40 fatevi prendere
50 cioè pensate quanto è difficile è
difficilissimo suo livello è fermo ok ok
state fermi e zitti non ridete mi date
fastidio
vorrei allora in tutto questo mi darebbe
una consistente mano trovare il coso che
mi dice dove che sono perché c'è cosa mi
dice dove sono i nemici ma ancora non ho
ben capito perché se no direi che è
veramente impossibile non difficile
impossibile
no ragazzi c'è veramente una credibile
centro fermi quanto troppo impossibile
sprint
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye perfetto di
dove la gema rossa che iniziano trovata
subito adesso un altro più
speriamo che non sia diviso in due parti
il suo livello raga perché sarebbe
impossibile davvero se speriamo che 50
finisce perché sono fucine una geologia
ma l'ho trovata fermi corri
eccola enemy sistan e doc è perfetto ok
20 20 mancano 20 shard ragazzo ho dovuto
tenere fermi i nemici per prendere
quello lì
mamma mia che culo ok credo che si siano
liberati a questo punto teoricamente non
lo so proprio così torino 21 20 ma c'era
fermo poi tra fermo no ragazzi mi serve
un'altra gemma vi prego date regala
temere un'altra
veneto 1 sono io scemo ne vedo uno
schema perfetto enemy scrive il prefetto
regale due come si fa in italiano
rivelati tra l'altro è un ora e mezza
che continua a cambiarmi i poteri perché
no non mi ha colpito non mi ha colpito
orco demonio norton stato ato ma che ca
pd ok al perché c'è la germania che ha
preferito
vedo i nemici già questo è un ottimo
aiuto vede ecco preferisco vederli che
stanarli perché se li vedo sa i suoi
esattamente dove sono e posso girarmi al
momento giusto quindi come avere uno
staff permanente
solo che è molto difficile trovare la
gema giusta 11 non è vero che culo non è
vero non funziona del trasporto solo
quando si ha voglia funziona perfetto
fermi e posso correre al contrario solo
che non vedo dove sono le spine quindi
non è il massimo ma pure quanti sono
cielo più un problema perché diventa
molto difficile schivarli 9 aspetta che
partono le spine poi corro corro dove
l'uno sta qua sinistra quasi il 3 in
fondo non so dove mamma mia labyrinth
incredibile nel trasporto dello scotto
misero di migliorini servizio di
trasporto delle sfumature settore con
uno o trovato mamma mia
ho vinto la
no porco demonio morto ricomponiamo me
ne manca uno proprio
cioè non so se sia da da sinistra hanno
fatto a lasciarlo di indietro ecco lo
devo uscire ha detto de mamma schede
gmail dove devo andare non torna
indietro
devo ritornare indietro immagino quindi
di qua giusto non si apre mi sa che devo
andare dalla parte opposta ragazzi che
non ci hanno fatto caso prima o valeri
uccidermi
ok occhio dovrei avercela fatta al
signori state fermi ma non è la mia è
stato difficilissimo difficilissimo
voglio morire però ragazzi ce l'ho fatta
altri shard devo trovare qui collector
short break del ring barrière ok devo
andare avanti salve buongiorno quanto
allegro immagino che io vi abbattete
trasportare per trovare stage ars oppure
domani la leva l'elevato che tira la va
bene 304 ragazzi faccio un tentativo
solo e poi nel caso perdo cosa molto
probabile lo continuerò nel prossimo
perché non so bene che cosa c'è stato di
vuole statue romane però fate la vita ei
300 shard così va bene ci prova una
volta ragazzi poi vediamo c'è una volta
nel senso tutte e quattro le vite poi
basta valeva vediamo la prossima volta
ancora perché mamma mia
sto diventando siamo sembrati non viene
né vi rendete conto di quanto sta
diventando difficile
avete aggiunto un miliardo di trappole
come dovrei riuscire a prendere 270
shard se siete pazzi maniaci 236 stai
fermo con quel lasciate la infilo
nell'ano solo giu no ragazzi incredibile
incredibile
di bile 2 26 mag
vi rendete conto che se ne avesse messi
cento sarebbe già stato tanto sono 220
cioè incredibile stesse completamente
impazziti comunque quanta voglia di
vivere posso fare suo livello
poi non ce n'è anche una 1 shard
speciale terapia esse sono tutti i
normali
qui non vedo neanche dove sono i nemici
niente proprio lì ti devi dimettere
no ragazzi incredibile ma no ma no è
impossibile
rimane una di vita una scuola l'ultimo
30 c'è l'ultima vita
siamo arrivati ai due c'è per me un
record già così come non arrivano
neanche più a 200 se ci riprova pisano
incastrato nella leva chiaro lorenzo
bravissimo e fammi entrare almeno ma
come ma lo sono anche entrato mamma mia
e allora per fate voi giocate voi fate
prima no non sono nemmeno intra già già
e mi imbarazza sbarravano la strada
mamma mi hanno rischiato io ho lasciato
speciale 195 occhio
no 20 20 shirt turo rottura o 100 città
almeno a metà siamo arrivati quasi e
quasi non voglio assolutamente tirarmela
almeno a metà più o meno ci siamo è
tutto il resto che manca mamma mia cosa
ho fatto a poco la parata incredibile
130 martin garics si vola ma ce ne sono
quattro vicini ma giustamente uno magari
non se l'aspetta però va bene facciamo
finta di niente
ragazzi questa la tarde cep shaun questo
era fa vj che si ammazza per fare un
videogioco horror
non vorrei mai più vedere una roba del
genere però le ragazze ok
spero che vedere sia piaciuto è stato
molto carino se non fosse così difficile
sarebbe ancora più carino bravo abe
dettagli signori come sede vicino al suo
documento mi piace utilizzate con il
ciclat ore fa vj tv per supportarmi su
dark deception
non è vero non esiste però usatelo su
fornito a caso di sistemi e schiacciate
anche la campanella che vi aggiorna si
video nuovi che escono che sono vi
arrivano le notifiche e noi ci vediamo
come sempre al prossimo vitobello
ragazzi
[Musica]